Os lo advertimos en un pasado vídeo aquí
en VisualPolitik: el nuevo presidente de Corea
del Sur, el conservador Yoon Seok Yeol está
siendo todo un terremoto político:
Desde que se hizo con la presidencia no hay
semana que Yoon no anuncie algún cambio importante
en el país.
Claro que, visto el historial que tienen los
presidentes surcoreanos a la hora de cumplir
sus promesas, habrá que estar muy atentos
de lo que finalmente hace y lo que no hace.
(En la historia de la democracia surcoreana
los presidentes cumplen de media en torno
al 30 por ciento de sus compromisos electorales.
Porque sí, en Corea del Sur se cuentan estas
cosas.
El ex-Presidente Moon, por ejemplo, ha cumplido
apenas el 17%, según los datos provisionales.
Claro que hablamos de estadísticas y eso
en política no siempre funciona.
No todos los compromisos tienen el mismo peso.
Sea como sea, el hecho de que el presidente
Yoon no provenga de la política profesional
coreana puede hacer que esta estadística
mejore con creces.
Por ahora si algo podemos decir es que el
tipo parece que tiene ganas.)
De momento la Corea que el nuevo presidente
parece querer dibujar se diferencia bastante
de la que dejó el ex-presidente Moon.
Ahora bien, ¿Queréis saber exactamente cuáles
son los primeros pasos que está tomando Yoon
para relanzar a Corea del Sur?
¿Podrían ser la puerta para un nuevo despegue
económico?
¿En qué consiste en la práctica el giro
a la derecha prometido por este presidente?
Pues bien, en este vídeo os responderemos
a estas y otras preguntas.
Pero antes….
¿Habéis oído hablar de nuestro boletín
exclusivo para patronos?
¿Habéis oído hablar de Latampolitik o de
los productos exclusivos que no están a la
venta en ningún otro sitio?
Pues si os gusta lo que hacemos y queréis
contribuir a que esta comunidad siga creciendo
y mejorando podéis encontrar todo esto y
más en nuestro Patreon, en la comunidad de
Patreon de VisualPolitik.
Os dejamos el enlace en la descripción.
Y por supuesto un millón de gracias a todos
los que ya nos apoyaís]
Dicho esto….
¡Arranquemos!
Queridos amigos, amigas, el sistema política
de Corea del Sur es presidencialista, pero
quizás una de sus características más notables
es que las elecciones legislativas y las presidenciales
no coinciden en la misma fecha.
Es decir, que el presidente del país puede
tener que gobernar sin mayoría en el parlamento.
Qué es justamente el escenario con el que
se encontró Yoon Seok Yeol.
Concretamente entre el día 10 de mayo del
2022, que fue cuándo asumió la presidencia,
y abril del 2024 tendrá que gobernar sin
remedio con un parlamento hostil.
Esto supone que al menos durante 2 de los
5 años que dura su mandato, el presidente
puede estar atado de pies y manos si no logra
el apoyo de la oposición en la Asamblea Nacional.
Bueno, o que durante este tiempo decida gobernar
más o menos a golpe de decreto presidencial,
que es exactamente lo que parece que va a
ocurrir.
(En Corea del Sur no se requiere que la cámara
legislativa apruebe todos y cada uno de los
decretos presidenciales, lo que le otorga
al presidente amplios poderes, ya que basicamente
le permite introducir grandes cambios sin
necesidad de alcanzar grandes consensos.
Y aunque a largo plazo estas medidas pueden
ser facilmente revocadas pueden llegar a tener
importantes consecuencias sobre la vida política,
económica y social del país.)
De momento las primeras propuestas y los primeros
cambios ya están aquí.
¡Juzgad por vosotros mismos!
T1 (¿MÁS MERCADO Y MENOS ESTADO?)
Como ya os contamos en el pasado vídeo sobre
el giro de timon en Corea del Sur, es que
si hay algo que caracteriza a Yoon es que
no le gusta ni un poquito nada, absolutamente
nada que huela a políticas de izquierdas.
Ni en lo social ni tampoco en lo económico.
[O al menos eso dice]
Sea como sea, es en la parte económica donde
previsiblemente más cambios se van a producir
durante los próximos años.
Y son tan relevantes, ¿Qué quereis que os
diga?
Nos obliga sí o sí a contároslos en VisualPolitik.
Pues bien, en primer lugar, el nuevo presidente
ya ha anunciado las medidas centrales de su
plan económico a cinco años.
Son ya públicas así que no hablamos de promesas
ni de elucubraciones sino de intenciones firmes.
Y entre ellas reducir las regulaciones a la
actividad de las empresas y las bajdas de
impuestos son las claras protagonistas.
(“Se mejorarán drásticamente las regulaciones
y esquemas que socavan la competitividad empresarial
y desalientan el espíritu emprendedor.[...]
Las circunstancias económicas actuales dentro
y fuera del país son muy graves.
[...] En tiempos de crisis, necesitamos hacer
cambios para estar más orientados al mercado
y hacer que el sector privado dirija toda
la economía.”
- Yoon Seok Yeol)
De hecho, tanto el Ministro de Finanzas, Choo
Kyung Ho, como otros ministros han dejado
muy claro en un comunicado que el núcleo
del plan económico del gobierno de Yoon será
sobre todo la desregulación.
(Con el nuevo plan económico el gobierno
se compromete a minimizar la intervención
estatal en el mercado y promover el cambio
de modelo económico hacia uno en el que el
sector privado y las empresas sean los protagonistas
dominantes.
Asimismo el plan también incluye reducir
el tipo máximo del impuesto de sociedades
del 25% al 22%, el mismo nivel que había
en 2018, revirtiendo, por tanto, los incrementos
liderados por Moon Tse-In.
Asimismo, y esto es importante, se plantea
una revisión del sistema tributario para
introducir una exención de impuestos a las
ganancias repatriadas a Corea.
El objetivo es resolver de una vez por todas
el problema de doble imposición sobre las
actividades de las empresas coreanas en el
extranjero.)
Y ahí no termina todo.
Yoon - como no - también quiere que en Corea
se emprenda más y se creen más start-ups.
Así que para conseguirlo su idea es otorgar
mayores créditos fiscales.
Por ejemplo, mediante la ampliación de las
exenciones a las stock options, una forma
de retribución a los trabajadore que consuste
en entregar de acciones de la propia empresa.
De los 50 millones de won actuales, el nuevo
gobierno quiere cuadruplicar la exención
de tributación a 200 millones, unos 154.000
dólares.
Es decir que si cobras en acciones, hasta
esa cantidad no tendría que tributar.
Con ello el gobierno espera poder atraer a
más trabajadores de alta cualificación a
las start-ups, y que estás puedan pagarles
una buena parte de su salario con acciones
en lugar de con efectivo.
Gana la empresa, ganan los trabajadores y
gana el gobierno si eso permite incrementar
el número de emprendimientos.
Y es que no olvidéis que estamos hablando
de Corea del Sur.
En este país la gente sueña con trabajar
en los grandes conglomerados gracias a sus
altos sueldos, lo que les permite comportarse
como una especie de aspiradora del talento
que daña la competividad de unas pequeñas
empresas generalmente poco desarrolladas.
Ya os hemos contado alguna vez el enorme problema
de dualidad que en este campo tiene Corea
del Sur.
Son casi dos países diferentes,
Luego, otra de las medidas económicas anunciadas
es la modificación del impuesto de sucesiones.
Y ojo porque este no es un tema menor.
Los que nos seguís desde hace un tiempo en
VisualPolitik puede que ya hayáis visto este
vídeo pero para los que no… creo que estos
titulares dicen bastante.
(Una factura del impuesto sobre sucesiones
que 'no puedes comprender': 10.800 millones
de dólares
La familia Samsung en Corea del Sur también
donará miles de millones de dólares en obras
de arte, incluidos Picassos y Monets.)
(El alto impuesto de sucesiones obstaculiza
el espíritu empresarial - The Korea Times)
Y es que, amigos, amigas, si bien Corea del
Sur tiene una de las presiones fiscales más
bajas de la OCDE, morirse, en cambio, puede
salir muy pero que muy caro.
Siempre y cuando, eso sí, tengas dinero,
porque según el Servicio Nacional de Impuestos
de Corea solo el 2,9% de los herederos de
personas fallecidas tuvieron que pagar este
impuesto en 2020.
Pero es que hablamos de un impuesto que en
Corea puede llegar a ser, atención, de hasta
el 50%, incluso entre padres e hijos siguiendo
una escala progresiva con deducciones, al
mejor estilo del impuesto sobre la renta.
¿Entendéis ahora por qué los herederos
de Lee Kun Hee el ex-presidente del Grupo
Samsung, que es el mayor conglomerado empresarial
del país, tienen que afrontar esa abultada
factura?
Pues bien, aunque este impuesto afecte fundamentalmente
a la gente que tiene bastante dinero [allá
cada uno si os parece justo o no] lo cierto
es que su impacto sobre la economía puede
llegar a ser considerable.
Veréis, como los principales conglomerados
empresariales en Corea son dirigidos por una
misma familia y por tanto heredados, cuando
alguien fallece la factura puede ser tan alta
que puede terminar afectando a la propia propia
empresa a la hora de emprender nuevas inversiones
o contratar trabajadores.
Por ejemplo, los herederos pueden terminar
endeudándose para pagar el impuesto poniendo
como gatantía recursos de las empresas.
Y sobre todo, esto incentiva a que muchas
personas saquen dinero del país y empredan
negocios fuera.
Pues bien, os guste más u os guste menos,
el caso es que esto es lo que Yook quiere
cambiar.
Aunque eso sí, todavía ni siquiera él parece
saber exactamente cómo demonios lo hará.
(Al margen de lo anterior, el plan de Yoon
también incluye otras medidas fiscales muy
importantes, como la abolición del impuesto
sobre las plusvalias de capital para todos
los inversores cuyas ganancias no superen
los 15.500 dólares al año.
A cambio, la idea es aplicar un pequeño impuesto
sobre aquellos que tengan más de 7,7 millones
de dólares en acciones.
También se permitirá posponer el pago del
impuesto de donaciones en el caso de recibir
un negocio de un familiar, y se ampliarán
los incentivos fiscales para las inversiones
en tecnologías estratégicas como los semiconductores.)
Pues bien, así es como Yoon quiere hacer
mucho más competitiva la economía surcoreana
e intentar sortear la crisis que parece se
avecina.
Pero, un momento, porque las medidas fiscales
no son ni mucho menos los únicos cambios
que Yoon quiere sacar adelante.
Hay mucho más en su plan estrella para devolverse
su viejo brio a Corea.
Atentos.
T2 (EL GIRO DE 180 GRADOS)
Amigos, amigas, el cambio que Yoon tiene en
la cabeza no consiste solo en bajar cuatro
impuestos y a correr.
Nada más lejos de la realidad.
El nuevo presidente quiere dar un giro de
180 grados en algunos de los temas más controvertidos
y delicados, como por ejemplo la política
energética o las pensiones.
Por ejemplo, Yoon parece dispuesto a cumplir
una de sus grandes promesas, una de las propuestas
estrella de su campaña: apostar fuertemente
por la energía nuclear.
De hecho, el primer ministro ha anunciado
ya un anticipo del plan que busca cumplir
con el objetivo de neutralidad de carbono
para 2050, pero en lugar de hacerlo con las
renovables como fuente principal, quiere que
la energía protagonista sea la nuclear y
las renovables sean su apoyo.
(Yoon pide un mix energético racional - The
Korea Herald)
Con lo de racional a lo que se refiere sobre
todo es a que el viejo plan de Moon para la
descarbonización parece de todo menos algo
realista.
El modelo del anterior gobierno combinaba
el cierre progresivo de las plantas nucleares
con una apuesta salvaje por las renovables.
El problema es que para poder llevarlo a cabo
el peso de las renovables tenía que crecer
hasta el 61 y 71% del mix energético, algo
que la mayoría de expertos consideran simple
y llanamente que no es factible.
(Por contra el nuevo gobierno ya ha anunciado
que volverá a retomar la construcción de
los dos reactores nucleares cancelados por
el anterior gobierno de Moon Jae In, y que
también alargará la vida útil de aquellos
que estén próximos a su límite.
Y eso no es todo.
Además planea lanzar la construcción de
varios reactores nucleares nuevos para aumentar
del 27,4 al 34 por ciento el peso de la energía
nuclear en la producción eléctrica en el
medio plazo.
También buscará introducir en el país los
reactores modulares pequeños, o SMR, que
se perfilan actores destacados en el futuro
de la energía nuclear.
Eso sí, el gobierno seguirá apoyando el
despliegue de energías renovables pero.
La idea en última instancia es eliminar para
2050 la producción de electricidad mediante
gas y carbón, que suponen a día de hoy el
66% del mix energético surcoreano.)
Luego sobre el tema de la vivienda, el plan
económico contempla reducir los impuestos
los propietarios para que estos puedan reducir
el precio de los alquileres y del jeonse,
el peculiar sistema de arrendamiento surcoreano.
("Dado que los riesgos a corto plazo permanecen
en el mercado de alquiler, el gobierno busca
dar respuestas preventivas extendiendo los
beneficios fiscales y financieros, y aumentando
la oferta-" - Choo Kyung Ho, Ministro de Finanzas)
Sobre este último campo, sobre la oferta,
el gobierno se ha comprometido a desvelar
pronto un plan para construir 2 millones y
medio de nuevas viviendas en el país.
Veremos.
Pero de todas quizás la reforma más delicada
es precisamente la de las pensiones:
(Corea del Sur es el país con el envejecimiento
demográfico más acelerado de toda la OCDE,
y se considera que su actual modelo de pensiones,
basado en un sistema de capitalización mediante
un fondo de pensiones público, no será capaz
de hacer frente al número de pensionistas
que habrá en un futuro próximo.
El propio presidente Yoon ha dicho claramente
que en su opinión el actual modelo supone
una carga para las generaciones futuras.
Por eso, entre otras medidas, quiere aumentar
la edad mínima de jubilación de los 60 a,los
65 años, o incluso eliminar la edad de jubilación,
u otorgar beneficios a las empresas para que
recontraten a jubilados.)
Y, ojo, porque esto no es ninguna broma.
Según la oficina de estadística surcoreana,
la población en edad de trabajar se reducirá
en más de un 35% en las próximas tres décadas
Un fenómeno que amenaza con hundir la producción
al tiempo que el gasto público podría dispararse,
no solo en pensiones, sino también en sanidad
y servicios sociales.
Pero este tema es tan importante que le dedicaremos
específicamente un próximo vídeo.
Pero eso no quiere decir que hayamos terminado,
en abosoluto.
Ya os he dicho que este nuevo presidente ha
llegado con ganas.
("La reforma de las instituciones públicas
es una tarea que no se puede demorar más.
[...] Las evaluaciones de las instituciones
deben llevarse a cabo de manera estricta.
[...] Los recursos económicos deben usarse
sólo donde sean necesarios, y deben gastarse
favorablemente y con generosidad para los
verdaderamente débiles de la sociedad que
necesiten desesperadamente el apoyo del gobierno".
- Yoon Seok Yeol)
Veremos en qué termina todo.
De momento lo que también ha cambiado radicalmente
ha sido la política exterior.
Ahora mucho más próxima a Estados Unidos
y a Japón, y más beligerante hacía China
y Corea del Norte, lo que ha supuesto el abandono
de la equidistancia del anterior gobierno
de Moon en los grandes asuntos de política
exterior.
Fijaos.
(Biden y Yoon valoran más ejercicios militares
en medio de tensiones con Corea del Norte
- Al Jazeera)
(El alineamiento de Corea del Sur con Estados
Unidos, en detrimento de China.
A medida que el nuevo gobierno surcoreano
profundiza los lazos económicos y de seguridad
con Estados Unidos, los expertos advierten
que es probable que la larga relación de
Seúl con China sufra.
- VOA)
(Tan pronto como sea posible tenemos que regresar
a los mejores días de Corea y Japón.
Si no logramos eso, por mucho que hablemos
del futuro de Asia, no creo que sea realista.”
- Yun Duk Min, nuevo Embajador surcoreano
en Japón)
Pero bien, creo que con todo esto que os hemos
contado, la pregunta es clara: creéis que,
si realmente se cumplen todas estas medidas,
Corea podría volver a vivir un nuevo despegue
económico?
¿Creéis que son suficientes para recuperar
la competitividad del país dentro y fuera
de sus fronteras?
Dejadnos por aquí abajo vuestras respuestas
y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvideis darle a like y suscribiros a Visualpolitik
para estar al tanto de todas nuestras novedades.
Una vez más, gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo, y hasta la próxima.